En 2017 se cumplen 70 años desde que la India
rompió con el Imperio Británico y se convirtió
en un país independiente siendo hoy, por
cierto, la democracia más grande del mundo.
En estos 70 años, la India ha conseguido
hacer funcionar un sistema político, con
más de 1.000 partidos, con una alta participación
femenina y que es totalmente inédito en un
país tan pobre.
Claro que, amigos de VisualPolitik, no lancéis
todavía las campanas al vuelo, esperad...
porque no se puede decir que en estos 70 años
de independencia las cosas le hayan ido muy
bien a este gigantesco país de más de 1.200
millones de habitantes:
la pobreza, la desigualdad, un perverso sistema
de castas y muchos, muchísimos problemas
con los derechos de la mujer han sacudido
a este país durante estos últimos 70 años.
Eso… y 4 guerras con Pakistán, que hasta
ahora ha sido algo así como su archienemigo.
Pero bien, si realmente queremos ver porque
decimos que la India NO puede sacar pecho
por estos últimos 70 años, nos bastaría
solo con comparar la evolución de este país
con la de China, por ejemplo.
Fijaos, cuando Deng Xiaoping lanzó en China
su política de apertura al mundo y cambio
de modelo económico, allá por los años
80, los tamaños de las economías de estos
dos colosos, China e India, eran similares.
En 2016, sin embargo, el PIB chino fue 5 veces
superior.
Atentos a este gráfico:
Y no solo eso, mientras en China el anafalbetismo
afecta a menos del 4% de la población, en
India casi 1 de cada 3 personas no saben leer
ni escribir.
Si,echamos un vistazo a cualquier otra estadística
los resultados van a ir en la misma línea.
Teniendo en cuenta todo esto, casi podríamos
llegar a la conclusión de que lo único bueno
que ha conseguido este país ha sido su democracia,
¿verdad?
Pues esperad un momento… porque parece que
todo este oscuro panorama de pobreza e injusticias
está empezando a cambiar.
Cada vez más expertos apuestan porque el
s.XXI va a ser sobre todo, el siglo de la India.
Es decir, que durante las próximas décadas
vamos a ser testigos de cómo este país pasa
del “Tercer Mundo” a convertirse en toda
una potencia económica.
Muchas empresas, como Amazon y Apple apuestan
por esta transformación y están prestando
mucha atención a este mercado.
Y es que entienden, amigos, que si se cumplen
las expectativas en los próximos años podríamos
ver uno de los mayores negocios de la historia.
(Y no se trata solo de las empresas: el propio
gobierno nacional indio tiene unas expectativas
muy altas para los próximos años.
En Nueva Delhi, la capital, confían en que
la transformación del país sea tan importante
como la que ha vivido China en las últimas
décadas.
De momento sus objetivos para los próximos
10 años son importantes: el gobierno aspira
construir 6 nuevos macropuertos, 250 aeropuertos
o a impulsar, atentos, más de 150 millones
de viviendas nuevas y accesibles).
En otras, palabras… todo apunta a que podemos
estar a punto de ver el gran despegue de la
India. Qué bien, ¿verdad?
Pues tened presente una cosa, en Pekín no
piensan lo mismo, para nada.
RECELOS Y DESCONFIANZA
China es el principal socio comercial de la
India.
Sin embargo, a pesar de ello, las autoridades
chinas están mirando con mucho recelo la
creciente capacidad económica, política
y militar de la India.
En un momento en el que China quiere ganar
influencia política, consideran que la emergencia
de India no es una buena noticia para sus
intereses.
Y es que amigos, en Pekín saben bien que
la India no es un rival más, para nada.
Mirad, algunos analistas afirman que la India
ha superado ya a China como el país más
poblado del mundo.
Y, desde luego, el resto tienen claro que
si no ha ocurrido ya, ocurrirá en menos de
una década.
Ojo, porque por culpa de la política del
hijo único que estuvo muchos años vigente
en China, la población india tiene, y tendrá,
más jóvenes y menos ancianos. Toda una ventaja.
La India es tal vez el único país de Asia
con la suficiente capacidad potencial como
para hacer de contrapeso al poder político
de China en la región.
Ahora... No penséis que este sentimiento
se queda solo en los despachos, para nada.
Esta creciente rivalidad tiene también su
reflejo en la calle.
Tal vez porque ha sido un mensaje alimentado
por sus gobiernos, tal vez porque la competencia
nunca es bienvenida, lo cierto es que tanto
los indios como los chinos lo tienen... muy claro:
sus respectivos vecinos son sus grandes
rivales.
Atentos a los datos:
(Según una encuesta de 2016 del Pew Research
Center, tan solo el 26% de los chinos tienen
una opinión favorable de la India.
Por su parte, los indios no se muestran mucho
más optimistas con su vecino: en este país
apenas 1 de cada 3 personas tienen una impresión
favorable de China.
Además,por si no fuese suficiente, 7 de cada
10 indios están bastante preocupados por
el empuje militar de Pekín y consideran que
la influencia económica de China en su país
no es nada positiva).
Bueno, de todas formas hay que decir, como
curiosidad, que a pesar de todos estos números:
Bollywood empieza a gustar en China…
Este verano, por ejemplo, hemos visto como
Dangal, una superproducción india, arrasaba
en las taquillas chinas y se convertía en
una de las películas con mayor recaudación
en China de todos los tiempos.
Eso sí, no penséis que esto es algo intrascendente,
no. Este incipiente éxito de Bollywood tampoco
ha gustado nada a las autoridades chinas,
que, la verdad, empiezan a estar un pelin
obsesionadas y ven en la influencia cultural
otra grave amenaza.
(“En términos de poder blando, la India
lo ha hecho mucho mejor que China [...] Aunque
la economía de la India no está tan desarrollada,
han puesto un gran énfasis en promover su
cultura”. Jiang Jingkui.
De todas formas, ojala todas las tensiones
se diesen en un terreno tan, como decirlo,
pacífico… desgraciadamente la realidad no es así.
DISPUTAS EN EL HIMALAYA
Mientras todo el mundo miraba a Pyongyang
y la crisis nuclear en Corea del Norte ocupaba
todas las portadas de los medios de comunicación,
otra crisis política estuvo a punto de hacer
saltar chispas.
(Ocurrió en pleno Himalaya, a más de 4.000
metros de altura, en el que tal vez sea uno
de los lugares más remotos de la tierra:
la meseta de Doklam.
En este lugar, entre junio y agosto, se vivió
una de las crisis políticas entre China e
India más serias desde hace 55 años, cuando
tropas del ejército chino invadieron el norte
de la India).
Veréis, el pasado 8 de junio de 2017, un
pelotón de guardias fronterizos chinos y
un equipo de construcción entraron en este
territorio que está en disputa entre China
y el pequeño y cerrado reino de Bután.
¿Bután? ¿El país de la Felicidad Nacional
Bruta? - por cierto un día tenemos que hablar
de eso, aquí en VisualPolitik.
Pues bien, el caso es que las unidades chinas
destruyeron varios bunkers utilizados por
el ejército real de Bután y empezaron a
construir una carretera.
(Bien, conforme a varios acuerdos en vigor
desde los años 40, la protección de Bután
le corresponde a la India, así que el día
16 tropas indias llegaron y bloquearon la
construcción de la carretera).
Bien, hasta aquí, un típico conflicto de
fronteras...empezando porque a Bután este
terreno inhóspito le da un poco igual.
Sin embargo, la tensión lejos de diluirse
fue a más...y la discusión entre Pekín
y Nueva Delhi se puso tensa.
Las declaraciones se fueron calentando e,
incluso, los medios estatales chinos amenazaron
al gobierno indio con graves consecuencias.
"China y la India están peligrosamente cerca de un conflicto militar en el Himalaya". Washington Post.
Pero, llegados a este punto puede que os estéis
preguntando,
¿Por qué diantres se le concedió tanta
importancia a un trozo de tierra que prácticamente
se pasa congelado la mayor parte del año?
Bueno, por una lado parece que el gobierno
de Xi Jinping quería probar a la India, en
un minuto veréis a qué me refiero, y también
“castigarla” por...bueno, por muchas cosas:
por su relación con el Dalai Lama y el Tibet,
por sus crecientes vínculos con Washington,
por advertencia... etcétera.
Y respecto a la India, porque el control chino
de esta zona - con presencia militar y la
nueva carretera- le pondrían a China a tiro
de piedra del llamado
"Corredor de Siliguri”, una estrecha franja
de terreno considerada estratégica porque
conecta siete estados del noreste de la India
con el resto del país.
En el mapa lo podéis ver bien.
Y sobre todo, más allá de cuestiones tácticas
por otra importante razón, la misma por la
que China quería probar a la India, en un
minuto vemos de qué estoy hablando..
(El caso es que, finalmente el lunes 28 de
agosto, tras muchos tiras y aflojas, muchas
amenazas y mucha tensión, las dos partes
acordaron retirar sus tropas y regresar al
punto de partida de todo este embrollo político).
Eso sí, hacía años que la rivalidad entre
ambas potencias no se visualizaba de una forma
tan clara. Y por supuesto, amigos, no nos
engañemos, esta meseta de Doklam, es… lo
de menos.
Y no lo digo solo por los más de 3.000 km
de frontera con muchas disputas territoriales
entre China e India. Hay… mucha más.
UNA ESTRATEGIA REGIONAL
Ante la posible emergencia de la India como
superpotencia, el gobierno chino ha adoptado
una estrategia: rodearla.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
En los últimos años China ha estrechado
lazos con Pakistán a cambio de 60.000 millones
de dólares en infraestructuras, especialmente
para conectar ambos países, incluyendo un
estratégico puerto en Gwadar que China operará
hasta al menos el año 2050.
Por otro lado una empresa del gobierno chino
se ha hecho con el control del puerto de Hambantota
en Sri Lanka, país con el que Pekín también
está estrechando lazos políticos.
Respecto a Bangladesh, China se ha convertido
en su proveedor de armas más importante.
El año pasado, sin ir más lejos le vendió
dos submarinos.
Y por último Nepal, que tras un conflicto
político en 2015 con Nueva Delhi, ha mejorado
mucho su relación con China.
Bien ahora fijemonos en el mapa:
¿Veis? La
India aparece rodeada.
(Sí la India no hubiese sido firme en la
defensa de los intereses de Bután y de los
suyos propios en la meseta de Doklam , hubiese
sido toda una advertencia sobre la poca fiabilidad
de este país, y puede que China hubiera conseguido
otro tanto con Bután.
Está es la estrategia de China para frenar
la tentación india de convertirse en un
actor regional influyente).
China, lo sabéis, tiene la capacidad económica,
el dinero, para hacer amigos con una gran
facilidad.
Y desde luego, el hecho de que la superioridad
militar china respecto a la India sea aplastante
también ayuda.
Así que una pregunta que surge aquí obligatoriamente
es: visto todo esto ¿cuál es la apuesta,
o mejor dicho, la respuesta de la India? Básicamente,
dos palabras: Estados Unidos.
Sí, así es.
(En los últimos años las relaciones entre
Estados Unidos y la India se han estrechado
mucho: entre 2009 y 2016 el comercio bilateral
se duplicó, y la venta de equipos militares
de Estados Unidos a la India se multiplicó
por 50.
De hecho, como ejemplo de esta creciente asociación,
todo apunta a que la India va a sustituir
sus viejos Mig 21 por más de 200 F16 de nueva
producción).
Y, ojo, porque  la intención
de Lockheed Martin, el fabricante,
es trasladar
toda la producción mundial de este avión
desde Texas a la India.
Una forma inmejorable de estrechar alianzas
¿no os parece?
Pues bien, ahora ya podemos entender mejor
no solo las tensas relaciones entre China
y la India, también la estrategia de China,
o la nueva estrategia de mano dura de
Estados Unidos hacia Pakistán.
Eso sí, todo lo que hemos visto parte de
una premisa: la India conseguirá emular el
éxito económico que China ha conseguido
en las últimas décadas…
Narendra Modi, el popular Primer Ministro
indio, del que ya os hemos hablamos  en este canal:
está liderando muchos cambios…
pero no tantos como el país necesita.
Pero esto lo dejaremos para otro vídeo.
Ahora, turno para ti ¿Crees que China conseguirá
doblegar a la India? Déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Por cierto, si quieres conocer mejor el poder
que tiene China no te pierdas este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.